IN THAT STATE.
PETER DOOCY, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
MEANWHILE, WRITING
"THE NEW YORK POST" "IF HUNTER
GETS INDICTED, IT’S AT LEAST
GOING TO BE A SIGNIFICANT
DISTRACTION FOR PRESIDENT BIDEN
AND RAISE QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW
MUCH HE KNEW ABOUT HIS SON’S
SKETCHY DEALINGS.
THIS IS THE KIND OF STORY VOTERS
SHOULD BE AWARE OF WHEN CHOOSING
A PRESIDENT."
AND THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN IF
THERE HADN’T AN EFFECT THAN AN
AMERICAN CONSPIRACY TO MISINFORM
PEOPLE LED BY FORMER U.S.
INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS WHO
SHAMEFULLY ABUSE THE PUBLIC
TRUST."
ALL OF THAT IN A QUOTE FROM
RICH LOWRY.
JOINING ME NOW, LOUISIANA
REPUBLICAN SENATOR BILL CASSIDY.
GOOD TO SEE YOU TODAY.
TELL ME WHAT IS IT, WHAT’S AT
STAKE WHEN YOU HEAR SOMEONE
WRITING ABOUT WHAT THE PUBLIC
DIDN’T KNOW GOING UP TO THE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION IN
NOVEMBER.
>> WHEN YOU LOOK AT BIG TECH,
THE SUPPRESSION OF INFORMATION
THAT CAN FLOW OUT THERE THROUGH
THERE, MANY PEOPLE GETTING
INFORMATION FROM BEING TAXED.
RICH TALKS ABOUT THE
GOVERNMENTAL AGENCIES BUT THERE
WAS STUFF OUT THERE.
WHEN TWITTER TAKES IT DOWN AND
FACEBOOK BLOCKS ACCESS TO IT,
IT’S PROBABLY IN MY MIND THE
MORE IMPORTANT THING.
IT’S PUTTING YOUR THUMB ON THE
SCALE OF PUBLIC INFORMATION IN A
WAY WHICH DEFINITELY BENEFITS
ONE SIDE.
CLEARLY NEVER DID THAT FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Harris: I AM SO CURIOUS, AS
A MEMBER OF THE SENATE, YOU
WOULD KNOW THIS.
EVERYTHING IS ON THE LINE WITH
RETAINING REPUBLICAN MAJORITY AT
THIS POINT.
HOW DOES IT WORK TO ENSURE THAT
ANY INVESTIGATION ON FORTH IF
IT’S DEEMED NECESSARY AND
IMPORTANT, SUCH AS THE HUNTER
BIDEN --
WHO IN THE SENATE REALLY WOULD
SAY YEAH, LET’S GET THAT DONE.
>> DEPENDS UPON WHO HAS CONTROL
OF THE SENATE.
IT DEPENDS UPON WHO HAS CONTROL
SO GEORGIA KIND OF DETERMINES
THAT.
IF YOU CARE ABOUT HUNTER BIDEN,
NO ONE SHOULD BE GUILTY UNLESS
PROVEN GUILTY BUT NO ONE SHOULD
BE ABOVE THE LAW.
NOW IF THERE IS A REPUBLICAN
SENATE, THEY WILL MAKE SURE THE
INVESTIGATION IS THOROUGH AND
THAT NO ONE IS ABOVE THE LAW,
NOT EVEN THE CHILD OF A
PRESIDENTS.
ON THE OTHER HAND, YOU CAN
IMAGINE THAT IF REPUBLICANS LOSE
IN GEORGIA AND IT’S A DEMOCRATIC
SENATE, IT WILL CLEARLY NOT BE
THE PRIORITY OF ANY COMMITTEE IN
THE SENATE.
SO HOW THE SENATE DOES THIS
SOMEWHAT DEPENDS, IN FACT
ENTIRELY DEPENDS ON THE ELECTION
RESULTS IN GEORGIA.
>> Harris: THEY ARE GETTING --
GETTING TO THE TRUTH IS ONCE
AGAIN POLITICAL, FROM WHAT
YOU’RE SAYING?
>> HOPEFULLY DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WOULD DO THEIR JOB.
THERE IS CERTAINLY POLITICAL
OVERTONES BY WHICH PEOPLE DECIDE
WHAT TO INVESTIGATE AND WHAT NOT
TO.
>> Harris: I WANT TO GET TO
SOMETHING THAT YOU BEEN PART OF
BIPARTISANSHIPWISE THAT SO
CRITICAL.
FOX NEWS TOLD SPEAKER PELOSI HAS
INVITED TOP CONGRESSIONAL
LAWMAKERS TO NEGOTIATE THE FINAL
VERSION OF THE COVID-19 RELIEF
BILL LATER TODAY.
CONGRESS FACING A GROWING PUSH
TO GET SOMETHING PASSED, GET
SOMETHING DONE.
G.O.P. CONGRESSMAN STEVE SCALISE
RIPPED DEMOCRATS DEMANDING
NEGOTIATIONS CONTINUE.
>> AT THE END OF THE DAY WE NEED
TO GET THIS DONE.
THEY NEED TO STOP DEMANDING
RIDICULOUS THINGS LIKE BAILING
OUT FAILED STATES.
THEY WERE TRYING TO GIVE CHECKS
TO PEOPLE HERE ILLEGALLY IN THE
COUNTRY.
I HOPE WE GET THIS DONE THIS
WEEK.
SHOULD HAVE BEEN DONE BACK IN
SEPTEMBER.
>> Harris: SENATOR CASSIDY, I
MENTION THAT YOU’RE PART OF A
BIPARTISAN GROUP OF LAWMAKERS
THAT PRESENTED A TWO-PART RELIEF
PACKAGE YESTERDAY.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THAT
AND DO YOU EXPECT CONGRESSIONAL
LEADERS TO CONSIDER IT?
>> I THINK IT WILL BE THE BASIS
OF OUR CONGRESSIONAL LEADERS
GOING FORWARD.
I DON’T KNOW THIS FOR SURE BUT
I’M TOLD THAT COMMITTEES ARE
TAKING THIS, THE COMMITTEES OF
JURISDICTION, AGRICULTURE FOR
EXAMPLE, TAKING AN AGRICULTURAL
SECTION, THAT’S THE BASIS OF
WHAT THEY’RE GOING TO ADVANCE TO
THE FINAL NEGOTIATION.
THE SECOND PART OF THE PACKAGE,
WHICH IS THE LIABILITY RELIEF IN
STATE AND LOCAL AID, THEY GO AS
A PACKAGE.
REPUBLICANS DEMANDING WE HAVE
LIABILITY RELIEF FROM THE SMALL
BUSINESS TO A YEAR AGO, SHIFTING
REGULATIONS, NOW MAYBE GETTING
SUED BECAUSE THE SHIFTING
REGULATIONS DIDN’T GIVE
GUIDANCE.
WE WANT LIABILITY RELIEF.
DEMOCRATS WANT STATE AND LOCAL
AID WHICH BY THE WAY WITH
SAFEGUARDS I’M OKAY WITH STATE
AND LOCAL AID BUT REPUBLICANS
NONETHELESS SAY IF YOU’RE
GETTING STATE AND LOCAL AID, WE
WANT LIABILITY.
SO FAR WE’VE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
FIND AGREEMENT ON LIABILITY.
SO THAT PORTION OF THE PACKAGE
IS NOT MOVING.
IT CAN MOVE.
BUT THERE WOULD HAVE TO BE SOME
AGREEMENT BY DEMOCRATS ON OUR
PROPOSAL FOR LIABILITY
PROTECTION.
>> Harris: SO PEOPLE ARE
CLEAR, THE ONE PACKAGE THAT
INCLUDES THE STIMULUS, THE STUFF
PEOPLE ARE FAMILIAR WITH, LIKE
THE CHECKS, IT’S ABOUT 700 OR SO
BILLION DOLLARS.
160 OR SO BILLION IS PART TWO
WITH THE LIABILITY.
>> CAN I CORRECT YOU?
THE 748 IS ONLY FOR EMERGENCY
RELIEF.
IT IS NOT A STIMULUS BILL.
IT DOESN’T HAVE THE CHECKS THAT
YOU REFERENCED.
IT DOES HAVE MONEY TO SMALL
BUSINESSES.
THE NF IP SUGGESTING ONE 1 OUT O
GOING TO GO BANKRUPT IF THEY
DON’T GET HELP.
IT HELPS WITH VACCINE
DISTRIBUTION, MORE TESTING
DOLLARS, HELPING SCHOOLS STAY
OPEN, HELPING FOLKS WITH
UNEMPLOYMENT RELIEF.
HELPING LANDLORDS AND RENTERS
GET TO THE NEXT COUPLE MONTHS.
THERE’S A LOT OF RELIEF THERE.
BUT IT’S NOT A STIMULUS BILL.
>> Harris: THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR MAKING THAT CLEAR.
FOR REAL PEOPLE OUT IN THE WORLD
WHO ARE STRUGGLING AND LOOKING
AT WHAT YOU’RE DOING ON
CAPITOL HILL, WOULD YOU SAY TO
THEM TODAY?
IT’S BEEN A LONG PROCESS.
>> WE HAVE BEEN WORKING ON PARTS
OF IT FOR FOUR MONTHS, OTHER
PARTS AT LEAST A MONTH.
WE CARE.
WE ARE TRYING TO MEET THE NEEDS.
WHEN FOLKS WENT HOME FOR
THANKSGIVING AND SAW THOSE LINES
IN FRONT OF A FOOD BANK THAT IT
EVER BEEN BEFORE AND SPOKE TO
THE SMALL BUSINESS OWNER WHO MAY
HAVE TO SHUT HER DOORS FOREVER,
EVEN THOUGH THE VACCINE IS BEING
ROLLED OUT, IT SHARPENED OUR
MIND EVEN MORE.
THIS PACKAGE GETS IMMEDIATE
RELIEF TO GET US OVER THE HUMP
UNTIL THE VACCINE IS WIDELY
DISSEMINATED.
I THINK IT GETS US THERE.
IF NOT WE WILL COME BACK AND
HELP ONCE MORE.
>> Harris: OKAY.
THAT’S SO IMPORTANT WHAT YOU
HAVE JUST SPELLED OUT FOR WAS
REALLY BEING TALKED ABOUT TODAY.
I THINK I HEAR SOME OPTIMISM IN
YOUR VOICE.
>> YEAH.
FOLKS KNOW IT HAS TO BE DONE.
WHEN YOU HEAR A 1 OUT OF 4 SMALL
BUSINESS GOING BANKRUPT, WON A
BUNCH HAVE ALREADY GONE BANKRUPT
AND WHAT THAT MEANS FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT, SPIKING
UNEMPLOYMENT, HOSPITAL BEDS FOR
FILLING UP WITH THE THIRD WAVE
THAT IT’S ALMOST THROUGH, I
THINK IT WILL BRING PEOPLE TO
THE REALIZATION THAT THIS HAS
GOT TO BE DONE.
WE ARE THE ONLY DEAL IN TOWN.
THE ONLY PLACE WHERE DEMOCRATS,
REPUBLICANS, THE SENATE HAS COME
TOGETHER SO THAT’S WHY I THINK
OUR PACKAGE WILL BE THE WAY IT
IS GOING FORWARD.
>> Harris: I LOVE THE WAY YOU